hier nämlich jetzt zugeschaltet dr
thomas aßmann hörstmann wir sprechen
heute und natürlich in den vergangenen
wochen besonders viel über die
neuinfektionen die zahlen die immer
erschreckender sind letzte woche waren
es über 4.000 neuinfektionen in ganz
deutschland am tag jetzt mittlerweile
über 5000 wie besorgniserregend ist
diese situation sind diese sprünge
tatsächlich also muss sagen jetzt geht
die post ab aber im negativen sinne
ich selber kommen gerade aus dem haus
besucht von einer familie da sind fünf
infizierte mit kuwait ja davon zwar eine
50 jährige im krankenhaus
letzte woche hatten wir ein sprecher
allerdings bei uns in der kleinen
gemeinde bei leute in einer feier waren
in einer sportgemeinschaft dann sind 20
infiziert und ihr geht natürlich überall
durch ich hatte letzte woche noch ein
gespräch mit dem gesundheitsamt und dann
sagte mir die mitarbeiterinnen thomas
weißt du gegenüber was jetzt los ist
da ist der april und mai kinderkacke
gehen sie wir müssen jetzt noch mal ganz
klar sagen es geht jetzt richtig los
und das ist eben auch die sache warum
unsere kanzlerin da sehr vorsichtig ist
dies eben naturwissenschaftlerin und
wagt nicht zum andern aris muss aber die
kann zahlen lesen und die kann auch
sehen wie sich zahlen entwickeln und das
große problem ist dass wir immer als
menschen von linear ausgehen aber der
entwicklung des virus ist ex
potenziellen also an der steilen kurve
hoch und das ist eben das problem dass
viele leute nicht erkennen und die sache
ist die wenn sie jetzt mal sehen wie
sich die spanische grippe entwickelt hat
da war es ganz klar die erste welle wann
schwach die zweite war massiv ganz klar
war die frauen relativ hohen
ausgangsniveau kam und da sind wir
wirklich in gefahr
sie können sich nicht vorstellen was bei
uns in der praxis los ist ja meine
mitarbeiter kommen kaum noch mit tempo
nach dir stehen bis auf der straße die
patientin
wir haben keinen impfstoff mehr
grippeimpfstoff ist aus der lungen
impfstoff ist schon seit monaten aus wir
kriegen den einfach nicht mehr
wir haben schon 500 körper kranke grippe
impfstoffe verhilft ja wir werden
vertröstet
ende oktober vielleicht november dann
kriegen wir vielleicht noch was also ich
weiß nicht wo der restlichen stoff da
ist und meine forderung ist einfach wird
dass die bundeswehr nicht nur zum
beispiel in den gesundheitsämtern ist
auch zum beispiel bei uns in den
arztpraxen unterstützend ist allein nur
verwaltungstätigkeit telefonieren und
zwar das sollte nicht in 14 tagen oder
drei wochen sein sondern jetzt damit man
jetzt schon die umgebung kennenlernen
weil ich habe die dicke befürchtung dass
das dicke ende kommen wird
ja und wir müssen einfach gucken wie
sieht es denn aus wo geht die reise hin
und wir gucken uns doch mal an in
italien wir gucken uns an österreicher
konvention niederlande die niederlande
haben jetzt schon ein kontaktverbot für
private veranstaltungen gemacht maximal
drei leute durch wonach hausen sehen ja
wenn wir nicht aufpassen geht das hier
richtig ab und deswegen müssen wir jetzt
schon ein bisschen vorsichtig sein und
da kann ich muss einmal ganz kurz auf
etwas was sie gerade gesagt haben
eingehen und zwar mit den
grippeschutzimpfungen der natürlich
haben wir jetzt alle gehört wir sollen
uns bitte impfen lassen das wäre
zumindest der erste kleine schritt und
jetzt sagen sie sie haben gerade gar
keine impfungen mehr
wir haben heute vormittag eine
pressekonferenz von jens spahn gehört
dort wurde das auch gesagt und man fragt
sich aber die grippewelle die grippe
phase das ist ja keine überraschung die
es jedes jahr da wie kann es also sein
dass man jetzt zu wenig impfungen hat
ich kann es nicht verstehen bin ich ganz
ehrlich mir wissen sie als ich das
gehört habe dachte ich mir warum habe
ich nicht nur 500 also gerne würden
gerne noch impfstoff nehmen wir hoffen
dass wir ende oktober noch 150 impfungen
kriegen können sich nicht vorstellen die
teilweise in der praxis die patienten
unnötig sind und auch teilweise
aggressiv gegenüber meiner mitarbeiterin
also gerne hätten wir im stock wir
wissen noch nicht wo wir haben jetzt die
möglichkeit vielleicht nochmal ende
november im stoff zu bekommen aber auch
das ist mir im großen fragezeichen
also ich habe das heute auch gehört dass
21 millionen impfstoffdosen gelagert bzw
bestellt worden sind ich möchte gerne
wissen wo und ich würde mich wirklich
darüber freuen
ich bin da selber ein bisschen erstaunt
also ich würde mich freuen wenn das
alles so spaß aber wir müssen wirklich
aufpassen weil wenn wir nicht wirklich
vorsichtig sind pflicht uns die ganze
versorgung um die um die ohren gehabt
wir haben dasselbe 1 1 und bleibt hier
in unserem kleinen ort erlebt mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bate schaue ich hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren